[Musique]
on mélange et la journée
on rappelle le principe les chéris du
judge et des cartes ici on va prendre
chacun une carte et vous allez devoir
subir le gage en silence c'est vous qui
faisait cette émission sur w9 on adoré
alors c'est très simple on a tous il ya
des cartes ici
regardez il ya du baby-sitting 2 partout
partout partout partout partout partout
à temps partout partout partout partout
sauf il ya celle là et vous alors
attention je vais les mélanges et je
vais mélanger et y en a trop déjà je
mourrai exactement on est un 3 4 5 6 on
rajoute je suis tombé la boj va bien
monsieur d'infos que soit la mesure où
c'est ça chez moi ça fait super plaisir
à 7 et un bénin du coup c'est que là
alors par contre il ya un truc c'est
important c'est cote
ouais on a tous la carte répondre
jusqu'à 3 avant de la retourner
exactement voilà on danse on joue pour
l'agent la lap dance brésilienne c'est
facile le perdant aura droit à une
lapdance très chaude sur une chaîne par
notre sur une chaise d'ailleurs par
notre charmeuse dans ce mondial ricardo
qui la saga qui la smac rahal afin
qu'ils assurent quoi ou la drac rappelle
monsieur attention à 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle
quelle horreur
on sent tout achat tous les trucages
k
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment le perdant se veut rabbani jaune
et le visage d'une substance collante
puis ce 33 la tête dans un seau de
confettis c'est le masque de cartons
angoulême lundi nerveux je m'en fous moi
aussi j'ai des dîners moi aussi j'ai ma
vie ça sur ses parties alors attention
au mélange est allé à main attention
vous mettez la mettez votre main de ses
chais la neige et les médecins de
regarder vous avez vu tout entendu
non attention à 2 2 3 radars
[Applaudissements]
le fond à la voix lasse et or il a dans
ton manteau bleu menthe ou du champion
n'entend ni champions la barre à
l'arrivée et le nez tu senti on regarde
est le nez le nez le nez de dorothée
qu'on se le dise tenir à cette année
dans sa valise toi tu fais comme ça
attention d'accord j'ai rien fait en
fait mal toi va vers le bol parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
celui qui a la tête de mort devra faire
le mojito xxl pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent pour l'instant on a fait deux
fois ce jeu soit notre ami camille
combal
je suis noir voilà et n'était pas bien
là le perdant se placera dans cette
baignoire et des autres on lui verser
tous les ingrédients du mojito rate à
dire beaucoup de glace un saut demande
un saut de sucre de canne de l'autre est
fraîche et ensuite on lui donnera une
grosse panne et il pourra boire mais
sympa si très simple et sympa attention
un deux trois
[Applaudissements]
julie
renvoyez gentiment le 10 066 mouillait
si nous des essais
allez vous
et ça va moins ça va les yeux monsieur
rouzier et maintenant je propose qu'on
regrette six fois sa série suivra à l'e3
alors on va mettre métier d'abord
les yeux on va mettre maintenant bosco
matin boulevard est d'abord le jeu c'est
trop on se dira par la glace attention
maintenant le sucre de canon
[Applaudissements]
et à
allez et enfin on va mettre la glace et
et glacis fulham est allé les invités à
les lacets mathieu de la solution pas
les yeux pas déçu zizi à son
[Musique]
on mélange elle a indiqué leva et cas
mais il va boire il veut voir un petit
peu camille avec plaisir avec le jeu de
chaussettes allait alléger mon cas mais
dites-nous si c'est bon c'est non alors
c'est pas si mal je suis il prend goût
petit quizz et pas dégueu mais alors est
ce que voulaient voir les images de la
pub à l'école est sûre vous avez triché
mais crise ou pas on regarde les images
et vous et vous me direz si vous
considérez que ce que j'ai fait c'est
tricher regarde vous me direz peut-être
vous n'avez pas considérer que c'est
tricher
j'ai une idée je tends vers une idée
vous considérerez également chez vous
sur twitter astag triche
regardez
[Musique]
enora
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]